louis ha comido con su familia en un
restaurante el total de la cuenta por la
familia fue 52 dólares y luís quedó
contento con el servicio por lo que va a
dejar 25 por ciento de propina él desea
saber la cantidad total la cantidad
total que debe dejar en la mesa elige la
ecuación que puede usar louis y
determina el total de la cuenta
incluyendo propina así que lo que no
sabemos lo que debemos calcular es la
cantidad total que debe dejar en la mesa
llamemos a esto x hay varias maneras de
hacer esto consideremos primero la razón
entre la cantidad total que él va a
pagar y el total de la cuenta la razón
de lo que él va a pagar y lo que en
realidad fue la cuenta y eso debe de ser
exactamente igual a la razón entre los
correspondientes porcentajes así es que
si consideramos el total de la cuenta
como el 100% la cuenta es el 100% pero
él no quiere pagar tan solo el 100% él
quiere pagar el 100% de la cuenta más
25% de propina
25 por ciento de propina y esto de aquí
lo podemos describir como
x sobre 52 es igual a 100 por ciento más
25% es 125 por ciento y eso sobre 100
por ciento si vemos las opciones que nos
dan esta última es nuestra respuesta
intercambiando los lados 125 por ciento
es a cien por ciento como x es a 52
entonces podemos elegir esta y esto hace
sentido la razón de lo que él va a pagar
incluyendo la propina con respecto al
cien por ciento o el porcentaje que él
va a pagar incluyendo la propina 125 por
ciento con respecto al cien por ciento
es igual a la cantidad total que él paga
con respecto al total de la cuenta
veamos si alguna de estas otras opciones
es válida en esta se establece que la
razón del total de la cuenta con
respecto al cien por ciento es igual a
la razón del total que él va a pagar con
respecto al 125 por ciento esta de aquí
a ese sentido voy a reescribir la por
acá para que lo veamos claramente nos
están diciendo que la razón de los 52
dólares del total de la cuenta con res
al 100% y queremos encontrar déjame
mejor poner esto en azul
así es que 52 corresponde al 100% y
queremos ver si esta razón es la misma
que la razón del total de lo que está
pagando con respecto al 125 por ciento
así es que al incrementar está en 25%
también hay que incrementar esta
cantidad en 25% para obtener la cantidad
total que realmente se tiene que pagar
así es que esta respuesta también es
correcta qué pasa con esta la razón de
100 por ciento a 125 por ciento es igual
a la razón de x a 52
esta de aquí no hace sentido pues esta
es la razón del total de la cuenta con
respecto al total de la cuenta más la
propina y aquí tenemos la cuenta con
propina y sin propina si invertimos esto
como 52 entre x si se cumple la igualdad
pero así como están las razones no
corresponden así es que ésta no la
marcamos lo último que tenemos que hacer
es calcular cuánto debe de dejar louis
incluyendo la propina para eso vamos a
despejar x de esta ecuación empezamos
entonces multiplicando ambos lados por
del lado derecho los 52 se cancelan así
es que nos queda x es igual a 125 por
ciento sobre 100 por ciento que es 1.25
y esto que multiplica a 52 y esto cuánto
es 1.25 por 52 veamos
13 por 4 52 por 1.25 por 4 no no quiero
hacer un error lo voy a hacer mejor de
este lado voy a hacer de este lado la
multiplicación 1.25 por 52 2 por 5 10
llevamos 12 por 24 y 15 2 por 12
bajamos un cero aquí pues estamos
multiplicando por 50 5 por 5 25 llevamos
25 por 2 10 y 2 12 llevamos 15 por 15 y
16 hacemos la suma 0 5 y 5 10 llevamos
12 y 24 y 15 bajamos el 6 el punto
decimal 2 lugares
así es que tiene que dejar 65 lo cual es
correcto un entero un cuarto por 52 14
52 es 13 52 13 es igual a 65 así es que
el ruiz debe dejar 65 dólares en la mesa
incluyendo la propina